no es que haya una haya terminado la
guerra de declaraciones éstas se
mantienen cambia ahora si el llamado a
negociar de pongo ha ido líder de la
oposición venezolana que coloca estas
sanciones internacionales en la mesa y
maduro que ya ha dialogado con otros
sectores de la oposición dice que acepta
esta mediación esta mediación
internacional recordemos que estas
elecciones fueron convocadas el día de
ellas por el poder electoral para el 21
entonces la posición tres veces para
hasta elecciones de una manera unida
parte de la posición alejada a la del
líder de la oposición juan guaidó se
había sentado de una forma con el
gobierno a nicolás maduro a hablar sobre
unas condiciones electorales one way
donde los de este consejo nacional
electoral pero hay una fracción pequeña
de la condición de si lo acepta